you've got to admit when we went to
Italy we had a really good time I never
not admitted a guess it's it's
self-evident that we had a good time I
mean I don't understand a scenario where
someone would go to Italy on a free
vacation can I just say why not just say
yeah I had a good time I never said I
not not admitted it I never not not not
not not not said it wasn't true why do
all that why not just say sure how
efficient do we need to be with these
answers aren't we understanding that
there's complex layers to every
situation so if I give a little extra
information what's the problem okay no
problem it's just that I take this very
serious this is serious Channel 106.
this is valuable real estate you have no
idea what an honor it is for me to have
this channel
okay